and the business analyst role is the
role that you will have fresh out of
University if you leave University with
a bachelor or master degree you just
start out in Consulting this is the role
that you will have of course in this
role you will usually crunch the numbers
conduct interviews with clients creates
light decks so this is really the role
where you learn the ropes of the trade
and for this role in a country like
Germany you can expect a salary of
roughly
€70,000 per year for a Master Level
graduate which is of course a very de
decent starting salary for a new
graduate you will have this business
analyst role for about 2 years